today on the matt walsh show last night
we were finally treated to the grotesque
spectacle of the man leah thomas
competing against the women in the ncaa
championships which he won handily of
course also we'll talk about that also
misinformation transforms into
information once again as the new york
times finally confirms that the hunter
biden laptop story was true of course
plus nancy pelosi is the latest liberal
to try to defeat putin with a poem we'll
see if she succeeded and a few
republicans vote against a bill leveling
more sanctions on russia is it because
they're stooges of putin or might there
be another reason and our daily
cancellation a film critic is accused of
racism for failing to enjoy a cartoon
about an asian girl did he bow to the
mob and apologize i think you already
know but we'll find out all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix mattress
helix has left the bedroom though and
now they've started making sofas the
mattresses are amazing you know the
sofas are gonna be great too they just
launched a new company called all form
and they're already making the best
sofas we've ever seen so what makes an
all form sofa really cool well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize a sofa using premium materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric the sofa
color the color the legs sofa size and
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
all form sofas are also delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping you know in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa it would take
weeks or even months to arrive and you
would need someone to come and assemble
it in your home all form
takes just three to seven days to arrive
in the mail and you can assemble it
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed and if getting a sofa without
trying it in the store sounds a little
bit risky you don't need to worry you
get 100 days to decide if you want to
keep it that's more than three months
and if you don't love it they'll pick it
up for free and give you a full refund
to find your perfect sof sofa check out
walsh and all form is offering 20 off
all orders for our listeners at
allform.com walsh
the leah thomas story has reached its
conclusion for now anyway in the not too
distant future we'll start hearing i'm
sure about leah thomas the olympian
crushing his female competitors on the
global stage but as for his college
career it concluded at the ncaa women's
swimming championship last night thomas
competed in the 500-yard freestyle race
we can't really use the word compete or
race it was not a sporting event so much
as a masquerade a minstrel show
thomas was wearing his woman face every
bit as degrading and appropriative as
blackface much like a professional
wrestling match the conclusion of this
fake contest was decided ahead of time
just a matter of you know inaugurating
the predetermined winner and that
happened four minutes and 33 seconds
later when thomas finished in a
comfortable first place setting a
program record in the process
now i wish i could say that the room
felt quiet or that the booze rained down
upon thomas when he completed the
process of stealing the gold medal
that's what should have happened but
that's not what happened the crowd
cheered while the announcers of course
made sure to as always respect his
pronouns listen
she's having a great race here and she's
gonna get second that will give her a
lot of confidence remember she's just a
freshman leah thomas pulling away over
the final 150 meters
had to work for it she was pushed over
the first 350 meters thomas wins the
ncaa championship ended up very close
for second
with wyatt taking it ahead of a late
charge from erica sullivan in third
[Applause]
[Music]
so there's your top two thomas on the
right
wyatt scoring an important 17 points for
virginia
yeah there's some uh talk online some of
these videos circulating and people are
comforting themselves by saying well
listen to the crowd they all they're all
silent and not cheering for for thomas
also you know there's some video of the
um the ceremony the medal ceremony where
they're standing on the podium and
that's the claim anyway is that uh well
you could really notice how the
crowd is more quiet for thomas
maybe i'm deaf or something but that's
that's not what i hear all these videos
it seems to me you can you can hear a
smash very small smattering of boos
maybe two or three people
uh but for the most part seems to me
that the crowd is clapping along by the
way emma wyant as you heard there was
second place so she was really first
place
the actual winner of the match was emma
wyant
um who um university of virginia and
she's the winner you know in reality but
in this fake world here
leah thomas is the winner and afterwards
espn interviewed the pseudo winner
thomas
the interview is only interesting
because the person conducting it is an
actual woman
if the full absurdity of this situation
hadn't yet sucked in sunken in for you
the contrast of thomas in his one-piece
bathing suit standing next to an actual
female
should really do the trick watch
leah how did that performance measure up
to your expectations coming into this
meet tonight i
i didn't have a whole lot of
expectations for this meme
i was just
happy to be here trying to
race and compete as best as i could
you've undoubtedly been under the
spotlight over the past few months how
have you been dealing with that and
reasoning with everything
i try to ignore it as much as i can
i try to focus on my swimming
uh what i need to do to get ready for my
races
and just try to block out everything
else what did that race mean to you
it's
it means the world to to be here
be with two of my best friends and
teammates
and be able to compete thank you for
stopping by
now not that it makes a difference
really but you can't help but see a
certain added arrogance in the fact that
thomas isn't even making any effort at
all to sound or appear womanly he's he's
simply just a man
who looks and sounds exactly like a man
standing there accepted as a woman
because he declared himself to be so
no additional steps required
yeah i think i've made the comparison
before it really really reminds me of
that scene in the office when um when
michael scott realizes he doesn't have
any money and he's told that he needs to
declare bankruptcy and so he just walks
outside of his office and goes i declare
bankruptcy and of course he has to
they've explained that's not you can't
just say it that's that's not how it
works um and that's sort of how it works
for leah thomas he's just i declare i'm
a woman well okay you're a woman then
now i hesitate to make that point only
because i don't want to give the
impression that the added steps of
hormone surgery whatever actually bring
a man any closer to being a woman uh
they don't but even so the lack of
effort here just underscores the
absurdity meanwhile outside a group of
protesters were on the scene to
represent sanity and common sense and
basic moral decency one of them was a
female swimmer with a say no to males
competing against female sticker on her
sweater
and she was not afraid to call this what
it is there were a few others as well
that were interviewed so credit where
it's due there have not been nearly
enough
female athletes speaking out against
this but here were two female athletes
who would uh and this is someone with
the courage to speak out and put put her
name and face on it as well
all the more reason to listen to what
she has to say here it is you're a
virginia tech swimmer what did you think
about leah thomas competing today as a
swimmer in this competition
what are you feeling what are other
athletes feeling it's a common
conception that we are all very
disappointed and frustrated with someone
who is
has capabilities more than us women have
to be able to compete at this level and
take opportunities away from other women
like i have a teammate who did not make
finals today because she was just bumped
out of finals and it's heartbreaking to
see someone who
went through puberty as a male and has
the body of a male
be able to
absolutely blow away the competition and
you go into with a mindset that you are
you don't have a chance
if that makes sense like it's hard to
compete against someone with
the aerobic capacity the muscle
development the body of a man it's hard
it's hard to think about it like that
and
staying positive i bet for other
swimmers who are in that
heat is probably
overwhelming i'm not sure i can't speak
for them but it's disappointing to see
and frustrating definitely and you said
that one of your teammates was crying
today because she didn't make the finals
uh you said that she was 17th and there
were 16 spots yes so leah thomas took
one of those spots uh talk to us about
what your teammate uh was going through
and that experience she was very
emotional and it's hard to see because
it's her last ncaas and
she really loves that race and it was
just heartbreaking to see that she put
all her effort into it today and when
the best time that she went in a morning
session before and still not make it
back
it's hard to see someone who works every
day every night
still not be able to
compete against someone like that
now there is no counterargument to what
that woman had to say but it shows you
the power of the left wields in our
culture that they have been able to
bring this kind of madness to fruition
without having to provide any arguments
in favor of it i mean talk about not
making an effort
they barely even attempt to justify any
of this
why should males be allowed to compete
against females well the left's answer
is in essence because we said so
anytime they try to go beyond that try
to mount an actual defense of the
practice it quickly devolves into
incoherence and gibberish for example
the washington post yesterday
published a defense of leah thomas
written by sports columnist
sally jenkins
and uh this is what she came up with
at the start of the start of the article
first paragraph she says hate to tell
you but in a way everyone is trans as
writer t cooper observed all of us in
life's competitive arena are on the way
to becoming someone profoundly different
than we were
and keeping score is just a way to track
the arc of a person from youth to prime
to past it if you subtract the aim of
becomingness from competition just
because you're afraid of elia thomas and
make it strictly about the chance to win
a prize then you might as well go back
to an amusement park and shoot a squirt
gun at a clown face because it will have
about as much meaning
now we're barely through the first
paragraph and already jenkins has had to
resort to abstract philosophical pablum
about the aim of becomingness
one side has a simple logical straight
to the point argument
males are not females and can never be
females they're different like that's
the argument right the other side has
the aim of becomingness
so jenkins has no argument nothing to
offer nothing to say
so instead she'll try to convince you to
be as confused as she is
and hopefully along the way she'll also
convince you that she's smart because
she uses phrases like the aim of
becoming this but um but you know you'd
have to be a very smart person to
realize that this is something that
stupid people do
when they don't have anything to say
they try to hide behind nonsense because
they're stupid
she continues
the debate over whether thomas a
transgender collegiate swimmer has some
sort of immutable biological edge over
the field in this week's ncaa women's
swimming championships will swamp
whatever she does in the water we look
to facts to rescue us when a subject
becomes heated but here the science
remains unsettled no one arguing the
issue really wants to admit it when is
the last time you heard a doctor or any
other expert say the words i don't know
but we don't know therefore to exclude
trans athletes from elite competition
out of our own constricting fears and
uncertainty is wrong harmfully so
the science remains unsettled she says
no her brain is unsettled
at least it isn't settled anywhere in
her head okay her brain is off
vacationing in fiji and she's writing
her columns without it obviously
no there's nothing unsettled here in
fact the biological distinction between
male and female is just about the most
settled scientific fact in existence
this is settled thomas is not a female
will never be one he's a man a male xy
chromosomes a male anatomy
as the women who've seen him in the
locker room have attested
male gametes
and there's a lot more to that there's a
lot more to being a male than just that
the physical difference between men and
women are not confined to the
reproductive system
they can be found in every bodily system
leah thomas like any male is male right
down to his bones down to his cells down
to his dna as i explained in my speech
at georgia tech earlier in the week when
thomas dies
and is buried beneath a giant monument
celebrating him as history's greatest
female athlete 100 years hence he could
be excavated and his bones analyzed and
scientists will be very shocked to
discover that the greatest female
athlete is a male
because his bones will attest to the
biological reality they won't declare
his pronouns or affirm his
self-perception because there will be no
self the self is gone but the man
remains
it also just so happens that
many of these biological differences
give him a distinct advantage over women
in sports especially swimming
i mean we could start with height
he is over six feet tall i think six one
at least six two looks even taller than
that
do you know how many women in america
are just over six feet let alone six one
six two it's like point five percent
of women are that it's it's almost
almost no women
almost no women in the world
are as tall as as leah thomas and he's
not all that tall for a man he's a
little bit above average for a man
so he's got that going for him
when he was in the pool he was swimming
against people with 20 percent less
muscle mass on average 40 percent less
upper body strength 33 percent less
lower body strength smaller fast twitch
muscle fiber smaller lungs smaller heart
shorter legs more estrogen less
testosterone a lower capacity to produce
oxygen when they exert themselves the
list goes on and on and on and on and on
some more
the side of sanity the side opposite
leah thomas and sally jenkins could not
be more firmly planted in reality could
not be more vindicated by the evidence
well on second thought that's not true
because the more we learn about the body
the more we discover differences between
men and women so that in fact with each
passing day our side is more and more
vindicated by the evidence
every day you think we couldn't be more
vindicated and then and then more
discoveries only vindicated more we just
keep adding evidence to our plate
while the other side makes do with the
aim of becoming this
and yet that side is currently winning
why well because they own the culture
they own the institutions also because
on this particular issue
our side waited too long to get engaged
i mean on this issue and like every
other issue but especially this one now
i was fighting gender ideology eight
years ago when there was only a handful
of us on the right who cared about it
and most other conservatives were still
offering breezy assurances that the
whole thing is a sideshow a fad nothing
to worry about
you really want to die on this hill they
used to ask me some of them still do
the answer was and is still yes
i've been on this hill i'm not leaving
it in fact i would literally die in a
physical sense before abandoning this
this fundamental fact of reality
i'd rather be dead
than claim that i don't recognize it
then go around
prattling off nonsense
because that's what's being demanded of
me like rather than debase myself that
way i would rather i'd rather have a
bullet in the head that's how important
it is to me
but many conservatives they abandoned
the hill back at the first sign of
serious pushback back when jenner was
being crowned woman of the year
others never took the hill to begin with
and now many of them are starting to
realize as some of us have been saying
for a decade that this hill is the hill
it's the central battleground of the
culture war
it took so long for the right to clue in
that now the battle for the hill is an
uphill battle they got to climb up the
hill first so they can defend it
a lot some of us have been up here like
outnumbered for a long time and now
we've got all these other people at the
base of the hill say all right i guess
i'll join you
eight years later
but that doesn't mean it isn't winnable
i believe we can actually win this
we can we can defeat gender ideology i
really believe that i'm not a i'm not an
optimist you know that
but i think this is one we can win
we're we're late to the game
a lot of us
are anyway
but we're not so late that we can't win
it
but it will require focus
and a united front and also moral
courage
all things that we've been lacking as a
movement at least in recent history
if we can rediscover those qualities or
discover them to begin with
this is a fight we can win
and we must now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
constant contact a digital marketing
platform that helps small businesses
nonprofits of all sizes build grow and
succeed uh with email marketing contact
management industry leading list growth
tools social media ads and more constant
contact helps small businesses connect
with customers find new ones and sell
online all from one easy to use platform
they've been trusted by millions of
businesses to help improve their
marketing with a 97 delivery rate
deliverability rate there you go you can
rest assured that your customers and
potential customers are getting the
right message at the right time with a
simple interface constant contact's easy
to use platform makes content contact
management easier than ever their list
growth tools help you find a bigger
audience fast leading generation landing
pages
text to join and social media ads are
proven to grow your list and drive
engagement with your brand with
thousands of integrations you can sync
constant contacts tools with the tools
you're already using powerful automation
tools help you send the right message to
the right person at the right time every
time to start your free digital
marketing trial today visit
constantcontact.com
yesterday was fun by the way i didn't
even mention
happy st patrick's day and me as a as a
man of irish descent how could i not
mention well i'll tell you why because
because this is
this is my okay this is our people this
is our holiday
and i'm tired of our identity
being appropriated in this way
um but i got home and you know my wife
wanted to have some saint patty's day uh
fun and she wanted to do um you know
arts and crafts time with the kids
which i was required to be present for
and um they're all making like cut out
three-leaf clovers and you know drawing
leprechauns or whatever so so i said
okay i'll join and um i drew a
leprechaun and uh which which i'll show
you here this is the leprechaun i drew
and my wife was so horrified by she put
her on twitter but that's it right there
so i just decided to draw an evil
leprechaun holding a dagger or maybe
that's an ice pick i don't know with
blood and scars all over his face and
sharp teeth
and then my boys
thought that that was the coolest thing
ever so then the whole arts and crafts
time took a turn
and they're all drawing these evil
disturbing
leprechauns and all this all this uh
like demonic st patrick's day imagery
and my wife was really annoyed and it
was great she's like i just wanted to
have a nice arts and crafts time and
this is what you had to do what did you
think was going to happen when you asked
me to take part in something like this
by the way summer can we put that image
back up there again i don't know why you
would just
go away from it so quickly this is this
is fine art can we first of all i think
we need to admire
my artistic ability to begin with
because i think that that's you know i'm
i'm not saying that i'm a the greatest
artist in the world or anything like
that but i think i'm in the top
100 anyway but i also think that um
there there are some saying that the the
my evil leprechaun looks a little bit
like chicago mayor
lori lightfoot which i can kind of see
that
and there are other people wondering if
i will sell that image as an nfp
which is not a bad idea as soon as i
figure out what an nft is
all right let's go
to this if i can find it okay from the
new york post it says a comprehensive
report about the ongoing federal probe
into hunter biden's tax filings
published by the new york times on
wednesday
confirmed the existence of the first
son's infamous laptop in october 2020
the post exclusively reported on the
contents of hunter biden's laptop that
he ditched at a delaware repair shop in
april 2019.
um the laptop's hard drive contained a
trove of emails text messages photos and
financial documents being hundred
provided we never did the one thing we
never i don't think we ever figured out
is who who could be so stupid as to
just leave your laptop
at a comp at a repair shop and never
come back for it
who does that how do you forget about a
laptop
um who's dumb well hunter biden is
stupid enough for that so i guess we did
answer that question
um and the emails detailing how the
president's son used political leverages
overseas business dealings the repair
owner uh repair shop owner reported the
laptop to the fbi which sees the device
and its hard drive
the laptop confirmation was included in
the times report that also revealed how
hunter biden paid off a tax liability of
over a million dollars a year after he
announced he was under investigation for
defrauding the irs
so this is something that the
the new york times they didn't they
didn't try to make it into a big deal
it's not like it was a big headline hey
all of us on the left were wrong about
this of course they didn't do that but
they they just kind of squeezed it in
and tried to move past it in an article
oh yeah by the way so it turns out that
was right
and of course this was i don't have to
remind you
this was
at the time when the story was reported
it was misinformation it was
disinformation miss and disinformation
this was all this was all a plot by by
putin and by russia
and not only that and of course you're
you're a you were a [ __ ] and a
conspiracy theorist if you would ever
believe
you know that hunter biden could have
material like this on his laptop um
and and not only that but of course
if you weren't allowed to talk about
this on social media or you would be
banned
you know the new york post a media
outlet suspended on twitter for
publishing
a news article
first time that's ever happened
in the history of social media it hasn't
happened since then
you weren't allowed to talk about it
now
you know when we talk about
um rigging the election
and voter fraud and all that
here's one example of election rigging
that there's there's no there's no
dispute
you know this is this is right out in
the open
this is a form of rigging the election
when you have
sensitive information damning
information about joe biden's family and
joe biden himself and his son
and there is a conspiracy yes by the big
tech companies and by the media
to erase this stuff from existence
they're not going to let you publish it
they're not going to let you talk about
it
it's it's not just that they've got
their competing narratives saying that
it's all false it's like you're not
allowed to post it or they will take it
down
and this was during the campaign
and why were they doing this well
obviously just because it would be
harmful
to joe biden potentially and they were
terrified
they they the idea of having another
email scandal
in the general election
that partially results in
uh donald trump getting elected again
they they couldn't handle that they they
couldn't let it happen this time
they let it happen the first time they
weren't going to let it happen again
so was the election rigged yeah
right there we don't really have to go
beyond that
and that's that's serious rigging there
when you've got the most powerful
institutions in the country
that are conspiring
to make sure that that
true true information
about joe biden's family is not allowed
to be shared because it will be harmful
to joe biden's election chances
all right meanwhile elsewhere in the
democrat party um nancy pelosi yesterday
made a somewhat bizarre announcement
earlier in the day when she was at a
press conference and she said that uh oh
by the way a little bit later i'll be
reading a poem
written by bono about
putin and
there was never there was never any
other explanation as far as i know it's
like why who
why is bono sending nancy pelosi poems
is there something going on between
those two we need to know about
and uh what's happening exactly none of
that's explained but then a little bit
later nancy pelosi gets up
and this is all documented by c-span she
gets up in front of a you know the the
the select crowd and reads this poem
that bono wrote about putin
um hoping that this would cancel world
war iii
let's find out if it was successful
before i introduce them i want to i got
this message this morning
from bono
and most of us we're always whether
we're in ireland or here or whatever it
is abano has been a very irish part of
our lives
and he said
this
he said
oh saint patrick
he drove out the snakes with his prayers
but that's not that's not all it takes
where the smoke symbolizes an evil that
arises and hides in your heart as it
breaks and the evil from risen from
friends from the darkness that lives in
some men but in sorrow and fear that's
when saints can appear
to drive out those old snakes once again
and they struggle for us to be free
from the psycho in this human family
ireland sorrow and pain is now the
ukraine
and saint patrick's name is now zolinsky
[Applause]
well that did it
world war three is canceled the war is
over
from what i understand
putin packed up went took well sent all
the troops home and that was it that was
the end of it
um that poem i mean
first of all nancy pelosi is that that
was a there was a terrible
i don't know if we can blame i don't
know who to blame primarily for this do
we blame bono or do blaine nancy plus
because there's a terrible rendition she
did an awful job i mean
bono sent you a poem for some reason and
you're gonna you're gonna you're gonna
recite it on camera
did you not practice it ahead of time a
little bit
try to do bono some favors here
make it sound a little bit better but so
it's a terrible rendition the poem
itself was was was awful
uh and in in in the
in the poem
uh zolensky is now a saint
and he's a saint patrick
specifically
so
between the song we played yesterday for
you and this poem
as as on this show we were just
assaulting your eardrums with the
cringiest material imaginable and it's
going to get worse from here by the way
i got to tell you we got a few more
things to play in a second and you're
going to really hate me by the end of it
um
but between those two things zielenski
is superman
jesus christ
a saint
a man who's going to save the world and
saint patrick's st patrick
my god we're just losing our minds
we're losing our minds
now this so so but the real question we
have i think
and i'm sure you thought this when
you're listening to that
which poem was better was it this one
was it bono's poem for putin
or was it the whatever that cw actress
who wrote the poem for putin about how
if she was putin's mother and if you
don't remember that poem
then
let's listen to it again
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light never
would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was your mother
the world would have been warm so much
laughter and joy and nothing would harm
i can't imagine the stain the
soul-stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly i can't
do it i can't do it that one's worse
that one's still that one is still worse
i mean
listen
that's an achievement in its own right
it's hard to out cringe bono
you know bono is kind of like
it is and has been
forever cringe made manifest
the cringe became man and it was bono um
so it's it's hard it's and given the
the field you're playing on here
cringy poetry that's bono's deal that's
what he does
and somehow that chick was able to outdo
him so you got to some some respect
there
and we're just going to gloss right over
the fact that pelosi said that bono is a
very irish part of our lives what
what does that
mean
this is what happens when we have a
bunch of 97 year olds running
the world at a moment like this
all right um we do have one more
extremely cringy piece of uh of audio
and video to play for you but we got to
break it up a little bit so we'll save
that i just i can't
i'm afraid if people are listening to
this in the car right now while you're
driving i don't want to be responsible
for people you know steering their cars
off of bridges and so so forth so
we'll we'll uh we'll break it up one
other story then we'll get back to the
cringe um
here's the article from insider it says
if i find it the house of
representatives passed a bill on
thursday to suspend normal trade
relations with both russia and belarus
amid the war in ukraine the suspending
the suspending normal trade relations
with russia and belarus act
which passed by a
42-424-8 margin allows president joe
biden to increase tariffs on products
coming from the two countries and
requires the us trade representative to
uh seek suspension of russia's
participation in the world trade
organization
um but there were
eight members of congress who voted
against it
and of course they're being condemned by
the media
and by the left even by people on the
right as being stooges for putin and all
the rest of it they're secret russian
agents i guess not so secret
well thomas massey
as you know i believe one of the very
few good ones left in congress
he uh and you can you can almost always
rely on him
to
um
to actually be the adult in the room in
congress biden was supposed to be the
adult in the room
turns out no he's just he's the he's the
uh the veg vegetable in the room he's a
he's the head of a head of lettuce in
the room thomas massey is the actual
adult in the room and he was with this
as well he explained why
he voted against the bill on his twitter
account he says this was slipped into
the russian sanctions bill on pages 19
20 21. it gives the president broad
authority to sanction virtually anyone
anywhere in the world
whether they're connected to russia or
not interventionists at the state
department are doing their happy dance
now uh and then he has the actual
he comes with the receipts as the kids
would say
it says um reading from it
the president may impose the sanctions
described in subsection b with respect
to any foreign person the president
determines based on credible information
so he can impose these sanctions based
on
against anyone based on credible
information
um
and then actually the section is quite
long so we can't read the entire thing
but you can go and read it for yourself
on thomas massey's
twitter account
so this is this is a bill
that again would give the president the
authority
not just to issue these sanctions
against russia but to sanction anybody
and this is what always happens this is
why
um neocons
exist
this this in fact is why there's so much
enthusiasm for war on both sides of the
aisle if you didn't know any better if
you're a more naive sort of person
and uh you you got to look at the
political scene in america and you saw
how divided everything is and how you
know arguing about everything we can't
agree on anything and you might think
that a subject like war would certainly
be the most divisive of all of them
given what we're talking about and how
serious it
is uh but that's not the case
we've got two sides that seemingly
seemingly
can't agree on anything
but when it comes to war they're on the
same page
and
the war and daylight savings are the two
things are on the same page
and that should make you pretty
suspicious
then you realize well why do they they
like war so much
because war is a jobs program for one
thing for the government
it means more money for the government
it's a fundraising program for the
government
and most of all it means it's an
opportunity for them to claim more power
for themselves
this always happens in any war
that's why the through the course of the
last 20 years and all the pointless wars
we've been fighting uh we also find that
especially the executive branch during
that time has become ever more powerful
because you can always hide behind the
war in the conflict to seize more power
for yourself and that's what they're
doing here and there were eight people
in congress who noticed it and had the
uh
the gumption to stand against it
all right
back to the cringe stacey abrams
appeared on an episode of star trek
um
star trek is apparently still
on the air i don't know i don't know
where it's being uh aired or what
channel it's on but star trek there's
still some sort of series of star trek
out there
and
i haven't watched any star trek at all
but
of course you know it doesn't surprise
me at all to to find out from this clip
that star trek is massively uber woke of
course it is
and in this episode they actually had
stacey abrams
guest starring
as president of the united earth now we
know stacey abrams
um thinks that she's the actual governor
of georgia
she thinks she should be president
she's a lot there's a lot of hype behind
her nobody can really figure out why
no one's been able to figure out why
stacey abrams is a thing what's what
what exactly is compelling about her
there's nothing interesting about her
her resume is not impressive
she's not even a charismatic person
when we know barack obama
had almost no resume to speak of before
becoming president
but at the very least he was a pretty
good public speaker and he had charisma
and so that's what carried him to the
white house
stacey abrams doesn't have any of that
but
she she believes that she should uh she
should run georgia really run the the
the country and if she can't do it in
reality then she'll do it on star trek
so let's watch this scene
we greet the president of united earth
[Music]
madam president madam president welcome
i am so pleased that you've come we are
eager to begin diplomatic discussions
nothing to discuss
united earth is ready right now to
rejoin the federation
and nothing could make me happier than
to say those words
thank you thank you all
what you have accomplished here we were
lucky to have each other ma'am
we couldn't have succeeded otherwise
general
i'm glad to see you recovered
yes i haven't had that close a call in
quite a while i would consider it a
personal favor if that were your last
close call
i never at your service madam president
captain may i have a word of course
uh i'm you know this is the future why
is there not
a polyamorous
trans furry as the united president of
the united world that's my question
stacey abrams is as good
am i even on am i in frame right now for
the camera
just barely okay i'm being told i'm here
we'll just stay here uh
stacy abrams is as good an actress
as she is a politician i'm just watching
that i i i it's it to me it's the
greatest mystery in life right now is
why like i get it i know you'll say well
right the left has chosen her as to be
their thing because she's a black female
okay i understand that part of it but
they're like literally any other black
female in the country would at least be
slightly more impressive than than
stacey abrasive you could point you pick
out anybody at random
she's not charismatic
she's not a good public speaker she has
nothing to say obviously
um she's not like physically appealing
she's not she's not an attractive person
she doesn't have that going for either
she's got nothing
and they've just they've settled on her
and they say no it's gonna be stacey
abrams it's going to be her because we
insist
all right
i want to mention this briefly from the
sun uh because i always you know i
always like these
space stories we went from
the fictional space to reality here or
what may soon be a reality elon musk
uh from the sun says illamaxus elon musk
expects to see another giant leap for
mankind not just in this lifetime
lifetime but in this decade he says
within seven years
he expects that we'll be landing on mars
the spacex starship a 400-foot reusable
rocket equipped with one of the most
powerful engines ever built will be the
vessel that brings humans to the red
planet since 2020 iterations of the
starship have completed four test
launches and landings reaching heights
of over 10 kilometers on each trip
plants take a crude mission on a trip
around the moon and the starship were
slated for 2023
and uh
anyway now he's talking about 20
you know within within before 2030 is
when he expects that we're actually
going to be landing on mars
and you know how i feel about this i
mean it's yes
i i would never want to go to mars
mars is like whatever it is 500 degrees
below
uh zero and there's these massive storms
that rage for months on end and as
there's you know
there's no atmosphere oxygen it's just
it's a death trap of a planet
and you're traveling millions of miles
to get to it so it's not something that
i would ever want to do
and it's hard for me to see in a
practical way how mars could ever be a
good substitute for earth
i know people are talking about well if
we ever need if we ever need to abandon
earth things ever get too bad here we go
to mars do you realize how bad it would
have to be on earth for mars
to be a better option
um i mean if it's that bad then we might
as well just direct our ships right into
the sun and fly right into the sun and
be done with it if things have gotten
that bad
but all that said uh i still think
you know i don't agree with the
practical sort of
justifications being given for this but
i think that's almost a cover story
what's the real reason we want to do
this what's the real reason that elon
musk wants to do it it's you do it to do
it because it's discovery because you're
reaching out to the beyond to the
unknown
that's why you're doing it
um
you know that's that's when when we went
through the age of discovery here on
earth
it's it's not as though
these these efforts were always very
very you know justifiable from a
practical perspective
but the reason that you're doing it is
because this is what humanity is
supposed to do
i think if you give up on discovery if
we say well we've we've discovered
everything we want to discover and
there's no point going anywhere else
because it's too much hassle and it's
dangerous
once you say that you've kind of given
up as a species as an and as a
civilization and we don't want to do
that
all right time for the comment section
who's bringing shopping carts back to
the rightful place
[Music]
okay let's go to clip 12.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're not going to talk about that
we're not going to talk about that
i don't know what that is that's not me
first of all
get that off the screen i don't want to
see that what is that who what
what it
we're not going to talk about that
that's not i don't know who that is
that's definitely not me
different glasses for one thing and i've
got a better beard and i have to say
you know
at least a slightly better physique than
that give me some credit what the hell
why why did i ever agree to why did this
was this my idea to do this video
comment section thing
it was my idea
what did i think was going to happen
just regret my whole life i regret
everything
all right
just want to stop the show
i didn't want to go on with the show
anymore
this is from lifetutor he says i love
how not subtle matt is about being
spoken to through his earpiece
we just established sometimes
mid-talking he just goes wait what well
okay what did you this is obviously not
a professional thing that we're doing
here okay it's me i'm just like i'm
sitting in front of a of a bedroom sheet
with my old studio imprinted on it
um jonathan says i agree with matt on
putting these people in prison but i
have to say
who are we talking about putting in
prison
mckenna
i'm on board for that i have to say
there are numerous cases where someone
is put on oh he's talking about sex
offenders so um i have to say there are
numerous cases where someone is put on
the registry unjustly that would be nice
to have fixed if possible uh yeah well
no that is true well that's why i say
with the sex offender registry my point
is that if somebody actually deserves to
be on the registry then that's someone
who should just be in prison
you know because the reason you're on
the registry the reason it exists
is because these are people who are
supposed to be
threats to society right um and that's
why they go in the registry now if we're
talking about you know you hear cases i
don't know how real these cases are but
you hear cases of uh someone who's like
they had to pee and there was no
bathroom available so they go behind a
dumpster in a back alley and uh someone
walks by and the next thing you know
they're on the sex offender registry
stuff like that or a case where cases i
have heard maybe someone you know a high
school senior is dating a
someone in 10th grade and then a high
school senior has a birthday and all of
a sudden now as a sex owner so cases
like that yeah they don't belong in the
registry but that's just that's
these are people who are
who you know don't belong there you
don't belong in prisons that's a
different category if they actually
belong on the registry then uh
then really they should be in prison and
that should be it
um
eli says isn't tucking what the psycho
and silence of the lambs did
yeah that's actually exactly right
there's
quite a lot that we see about gender
ideology and the gender ideologues that
that i think will often recall
uh buffalo bill from silence of the
lambs
sean says zelensky is the new george
floyd well that's not fair because
zolensky i mean george floyd
did nothing in his life at all uh of
value
i did a lot of bad things and then he
died and the only reason why anyone
remembers him is because how he died uh
zalensky is
you know is a is the leader of ukraine
he's actually doing something he is he
is trying to defend his country so all
that is
all that is good it's good that he's
doing that
um my issue is simply with and if if
if you want to point out simply that
zelinski is
admirable for defending his country and
not and not doing the unspeakably
cowardly thing of abandoning his country
and fleeing to some other country uh if
you want to point that out and say that
you might fine i mean so do i it's great
but when we go beyond that
and turned him into some sort of literal
savior figure
now we've gone several steps too far
green machine says okay if we're going
to continue doing these agonizing video
comments they have to be short like 10
to 15 seconds i could not agree more
i think in fact we should go to zero
seconds shortest of all well as you all
know at this point the daily wire does
not stop creating awesome new content
and we're super excited about our latest
docu-series fauci unmasked the show
exposes the most successful failure
failure in government history dr anthony
fauci it's hosted by our very own
michael knowles he'll peel back the mask
on fauci's past and show the world's
leading quote unquote scientist for what
he really is which is a fraud and worse
than that all that is exposed in this
the third and final episode dropped this
morning in it michael exposes the final
layer of fouchy's unnatural rise to the
authoritarian top and it's seriously
good that is the episode not fauci check
out this sneak peek
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way that 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america
doctor anthony fountain don't you think
it's time that you step down and let
someone else who has a more effective
message
actually no
[Music]
the latest part of the three-part series
is streaming now and is available
exclusively at the daily wire if you're
not a member yet head to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today the show is
excellent and since we're only adding
more content every day you don't want to
miss it also speaking of more content
the situation in ukraine is dire which
is why we're recording a special episode
of morning water to be released this
sunday with our investigative reporter
cassie who's joining john and georgia to
discuss her recent trip to cover the
situation in ukraine so make sure you
tune in morning to morning wire this
sunday because not only is an incredibly
important episode it's the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we're working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep the facts
trending towards number one so subscribe
and start listening now to morning wire
and apple spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts and leave a five-star review
if you like what you hear finally it is
once again time to announce the latest
installment of the matt walsh patch
program this is march's path which is
do i have a patch program oh i do yeah
this is the the patch for march godspeed
it's officially arrived and in case
you've forgotten
like perhaps i have
which i know you surely have not
i am releasing a very limited edition
patch once a month for you to wear on
your shirt backpack skin or wherever you
feel best demonstrates your allegiance
to the sweet baby king i'm really good
at ads can we just all admit that how
good i am at this
remember these merit badges are limited
edition last month's patch sold out so
don't miss your chance to be part of
history go to dailywire.com
shop today how could you not go after
that sales pitch now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
well pixar's latest film turning red has
generated some pushback from parents
who say that
the story which is apparently some kind
of weird metaphor for puberty
isn't appropriate for young children
also as we've previously discussed some
parents say that the protagonist child
is bratty and disrespectful and rude
this behavior you know is
encouraged and is not discouraged by the
film but is encouraged and there are
elements of wokeness sprinkled
throughout now this again is is what
i've heard from parents i haven't seen
the movie for myself and neither have my
kids and it will stay that way
i'm quite happy to take their word for
it
now i usually believe in investigating
issues for yourself before drawing
conclusions but when the issue is
whether this stupid disney film is
merely stupid or stupid and also
malignant um
i feel no need to look closer i'd rather
just save the brain cells
for something a little bit more
important but as we've discovered
it in our society um full of overgrown
children stuck in perpetual adolescence
it's very offensive to have a critical
opinion about a piece of entertainment
especially disney entertainment for many
people especially in my generation
disney and disney branded products are a
crucial part of their identity because
they have no real identity and then you
add to this the fact that the film stars
an asian cartoon character a cartoon
character of asian descent ccad and now
it's it's all the more offensive to
criticize it that's what brings us to
the latest fake racism controversy this
is from nbc it says quote turning red
cast members spoke up in support of the
new pixar film and its universality
following a controversial review for the
animated movie that was published by
cinema blend
the review was pulled offline after
being called sexist racist and more by
members of the press
cinemablend managing director sean
o'connell wrote the review saying that
the film's appeal was limited because
it's set in the asian community of
toronto quote i recognize the humor in
the film but connected with none of it
by rooting turning red very specifically
in the asian community of toronto the
film legitimately feels like it was made
for director domi xi's friends and
immediate family members o'connell wrote
in the sense polled review which is fine
but also a tad limiting in its scope
o'connell doubled down on his opinion of
the film in a sense-deleted tweet that
accompanied his review the post read
quote some pixar films are made for
universal audiences turning red is not
the target audience for this one feels
very specific and very narrow if you're
in it this might work very well for you
i am not in it this was exhausting
now from here we have the whole routine
where the media people on the left cast
members people in hollywood etc react
with horror that some white man dared to
not enjoy a cartoon about an asian kid
probably don't need to go through all
those examples
you've heard this tune many times before
no need no need for me to hum it for you
now but
we should note a couple of things about
o'connell's opinion first it's his
opinion right he's paid to give his
opinion on movies that's his job
in the same world that would be enough
no need to say anything further
there are no wrong opinions about a
movie
that's not true there are wrong opinions
like if you like star wars that's a
wrong opinion there are a lot of wrong
opinions but either way that it's your
job to give your opinion if you're a
movie critic
but we don't live in a sane world so
that brings us to the second point
o'connell's point essentially was that
he wasn't represented by the film he
didn't connect with it it didn't speak
to his lived experience which is to be
expected given that he's a white man in
america writing film reviews and the
movie is about an asian girl toronto
having her first period
now these days of course there's no
reason why a white man can't also be a
menstruating asian girl if that's how he
identifies but regardless this comment
about lacking connection with the film
is an extremely common criticism of
movies
this is the whole reason why every movie
now has to include a representative from
every identity group and sexuality so
that every viewer can feel represented
by the story
given this obsession with representation
why can't o'connor make a similar
comment about this movie
that's a rhetorical question of course i
know the reason
he's a white man
and white men are not entitled to have
the kinds of opinions that other
identity groups are allowed to have
now i would go on defending o'connell
from the absurd racism charge but
unfortunately he's made that impossible
after the publication pulled the review
they actually did pull a review
because some readers didn't agree with
it this is a movie review site and
somebody wrote a movie review and the
readers didn't agree with it and so they
took it down
but after that o'connell went on twitter
and did exactly what you already knew he
would do he tweeted
i'm genuinely sorry for my turning red
review
thank you to everyone who has reached
out with criticism no matter how harsh
it's clear that i didn't engage nearly
enough with the movie nor did i explain
my point of view well at all i really
appreciate your feedback
there it is the grovel the submission
the surrender the apology
think about the phrasing too it's clear
that i didn't engage enough with the
movie
he's apologizing for not feeling engaged
with a film he's not just apologizing
for how he expressed himself that would
be bad enough he's apologizing for the
actual opinion that he formed about the
movie
he's saying i'm sorry for thinking these
thoughts about a cartoon
he's apologizing for not liking it more
it's a pixar cartoon about a teenage
girl going through puberty and o'connell
now admits that it's his moral
obligation to connect with the story
somehow and enjoy it somehow he's
admitted guilt
what's he guilty of exactly who knows
but he's admitted it
and he's confessed to whatever racism
he's been accused of
you know there's a scene at the end of a
mystic river where sean penn's character
has a gun to the head of tim robinson's
character
he's trying to get robbins to admit that
he killed
pen his dog pen's daughter
now robbins didn't actually kill the
daughter he was innocent but penn's
character told him that he'd be allowed
to live if he simply admitted to his
crime
and finally robbins breaks down and says
yeah i did i did
and then pat pence proceeds to stab him
to death on the spot and dump his body
in the river
now a similar scene plays out with
canceled culture over and over and over
again
the cancelled person with a metaphorical
gun to the head
thinks that he can escape the wrath of
the mob by admitting to a crime he
didn't commit the mob puts the gun to
the head and says admit what you did
admit what you did
and then he admits it
and he's gutted anyway and dumped in the
river
now he was probably going to die either
way
now he dies a guilty man
now he dies without his dignity
there's no benefit to apologizing
accepting the racist label
the apology isn't even self-serving it's
self-destructive
yet that won't stop these people so
overwhelmed by their cowardly fear fear
from continuing to make this fatal error
again and again and again
so good riddance
you know i can't help these people even
if i wanted to
sean o'connell is not a racist
but
he admitted to it and apologized so i
guess he is
and he had the right opinion about this
dumb disney cartoon but he apologized
for that too so i guess it was the wrong
opinion
he bowed to the mob
and so today he is the one
who is sadly cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today thank
god
talk to you on monday godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin